also what's with this grim weird hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome back to dead dreams now we're
climbing the tree we're about to
encounter an error Oh more Morse code
find us ah find us got it find us okay
find who woman hey hey wait a minute
marv morale you should stop here sir
believe me you won't like what you see
well I don't think I like what I see
down here either so I don't know the
difference between being up there and
being down here
don't you understand those are my
friends I have to know no matter what's
in there I have to know no my grace
please I beg you don't make me do this
what are you doing why why are you so
wait a minute no okay yeah oh yeah
that's what there's one of those normal
things that you talk about that's normal
oh oh no Marv moral Mick what was his
name Marv min blue or yeah mumble stamp
okay oh darn net dark red like the
gemstone amber yellowish orange jewel
with fossil Luo lies resin Jade as a
color green is like the mineral stone
Clementine orange citrus fruit garnett
amber Jade Clementine okay am I supposed
to memorize this is this a memorize e
darn ed an birch a Clementine I remember
the last place I went into I kind of
needed to memorize something so I'm
assuming that it's gonna be similar in
this nightmare land
garnet Jade no grenade amber Jade
Clementine
garnet oh hi they called her Jade
their names were Oh
why wouldn't it have been garnet and
amber isn't that the answer Garnett and
Skye married and had a child called
um her parents were named garnet and
amber that's why they called her I got
that wrong didn't I okay you know I
didn't do my research really I didn't do
enough research
I wasn't researching enough sorry I
didn't memorize goodly enough sorry
about that sorry oh sorry red and blue
give purple red and yellow give orange
blue and yellow good Oh blue what's here
what is here what are you talking about
what's here need I saw that what do I do
about you they called her Jade their
names were oh it's it's talking about
mixing colors but I don't know why I
need to do it with him I could have
solved it garnet dark red yellow okay
red yellow green
there is no scar scar the scar does not
exist um so it's raw red yellow green
here they call her James their names
were
hey listen guy listen my dude I'm gonna
find a way to get you I'm gonna find I
don't know how what am I supposed to do
about that I didn't know that the mixing
of the colours was gonna cause such a
kerfuffle
Roundy buddy
okay so Jade to get green you mix blue
and yellow so amber and sky Garnett and
sky mare red and blue red and blue is
purple which would be indigo red and
yellow would make Clementine that's
correct
well why am I so slow though why would I
be so slow I did it I did I solved that
I did this puzzle solve I solved the
puzzle and I did it what is it doing
here no idea never saw before but it's
sort of cool right by the way where were
you this whole time you know just
exploring and stuff all right
look there's no water down here that's
because the railroad is going up a
mountain right where we're heading oh I
almost forgot here what what here what
is that for me yep thanks where did you
get it it's a Lulu do you hear that -
its card why does everyone have a DD in
this game sounds like a waterfall Oh
so what do you say Wow
I said it was worth it you can see all
the town from here can't believe I
didn't know about this place those will
be awesome do you think so I'm assuming
you're referring to the picture so she's
taking absolutely hey let's take a
picture
Aaron Thomas all right coming ready to
ciao guys what can you feel it it's
moving
are you I feel it too what the hell get
up all of you now oh oh I'm moving hey
hey
Oh get up get up get up get up pump me
up pump me up oh my god Aaron help him
help me help I swear I've made this face
this entire episode
Thomas you'll miss the train well
wouldn't that be a shame when then just
be a dick diddling shame what train calm
down I'm gonna I'm gonna panic I can't
stand up don't you want to see Aaron
it's gonna kill us
of course it will that's the point dummy
I want to leave Shh we're gonna get
through it together
as we always did our last adventure
okay in this face this face right here
cool all right cool thanks for the
nightmares thank you for that it's
jammed
apparently it's jammed everybody hmm so
where are my exact toilet air roar where
am i what am i doing am i in the tree am
i back in the tree what exactly happened
out on the outside world who got here
with a train oh hi Aurora Aurora I row
row row a row toilet area over all right
cool this is phenomenal fantastical
delightful even this is what I call
slice of something special okay here's
the vibrating angel I was looking for
you
what is happening I don't was he really
dead was he really dead who are we
talking about here we're talking about
the guy that got hit with the train it
was seven years ago have I been here
this whole time show me show me
everything so be it okay all right far
as I know you rose walking in on you on
the toilet firming toilets we're in this
place Oh
chapter two I don't know what these
symbols mean okay
what Oh
[Music]
you check the pockets of your old coat
the pills are still in place a glass of
water yeah take more okay eyeballs here
we go
pop him down and going for the record
all right just gotta keep slapping your
eyes up against my camera all right
can't be healthy for your corneas all
right cool I guess I'm done
enough for me please I cut it off at ten
or nine or however many I had lick see
nominator I have thank you lick seein
that I don't know what you said a little
bag with golden pills
all right off I go then may good
calendar who needs days April June
October half a past September later than
November eat my ass in December Bobby
phobia me no man having cover January
easy April June and November [ __ ] up up
three pieces are missing you found peace
D alright great
why am I here what am I looking for
Oh why are you soon din it's never a
good thing when it's sumed in a pro tune
October December and November my ass in
April and then we'll see December God
perfect
June ah this is June of course this is
June why would these be I don't know
that's how that was gonna be was a good
son and a loving husband it seemed that
he held it all a big house a beautiful
wife a high-paid job and wealthy parents
this news disturbed his content and
monotonous being the idea was born in
his head huh
what's the idea what idea are we talking
about here what's the idea what's the
big idea
what's the small idea what's the foggy
idea if platoon in October then you go
past August and then you circle around
July like a surprise attack and you stop
July in the back and then you look over
it man you're like
you're next [ __ ] january/february half
past your knees [ __ ]
July I'm gonna stab you July
what July's gonna stab me yeah I hate
that wait but where are you heard of the
radio okay all right I'm sorry I don't
like it what so you got rid of the pills
I didn't well I didn't do not took like
ten what's wrong with you I don't know
anyways I surprised some more okay how
do you buy anything
you're a radio with a mouth no you'll
never get the truth we both know you'll
never tell the truth huh I don't know
nothing that you know and you don't know
nothing that I know you're not real
[Music]
don't let her kill us is it July is July
coming I don't do it July I didn't mean
it Lola Google i/o oh that's there's a
bad that's the bad why does that mean
I'm goofed it's my heart am I getting
offed I don't know what skidding of is
there something invisible is it an
invisible thing
was it an invisible thing July you
invisible [ __ ] so what was I doing
oh this cave is confers only a put June
and October
then you remember about September yeah
you forgot all right
that's what who's there who's there
just a kid with asthma nothing to be
afraid of
all right that's fine just blinked the
demons that live on the inside of my
eyelids that's no problem all right
nothing to it but to do it baby of June
and October coming up on October or
September like a full-on PT replication
in a beauty came first
oh this
October's a spooky month all right we'll
do an an October
well here's October oh it's where the
pieces are this is a baby crib it's a
baby did you do baby crib
no would you want to run that by me
again baby I don't get chest by no baby
ever oh it's not in here okay cool good
Oh turn off the flashlight Oh
cradle to the grave griddle to microwave
what did i do cradle
I got cradle got a critic acquittal
squirting skurdal oh no okay stop it
I don't tell me to stop it on here okay
I don't know what you're talking about
but it sounds really inspirational and I
appreciate that I could use that when
I'm having a tough time right now going
through some demonic hellscape it's
really getting me down enough well I
could keep going no no way you're
talking about it's kind of nice relaxing
John Doe weird baby mother monsters Oh
what are we doing now April we made it
to April it's the peace is to Pisa
deposal it's the final piece of the
puzzle and I've got the piece puzzle I
got the piece of the puzzle end up who's
that this tree wasn't here before
I interrupt my own stupidity to announce
that this trees was is was not here
before
all right Z you see that's all right no
no no no one but the who of three four
uh-huh I know how babies are made you
one nice one thing about me markiplier I
know our babies become I know ah my head
what's that a dream where am i oh I'm
still me and by me I mean this guy where
disguises I'm bad with names all right
then
hello is everything okay I'm just gonna
slide right on by you know get her man
let's see what's going on here oh no
that's a problem look inside I see no
reason why not to
I regret looking inside that all right
did someone puke up a baby all right
that's what hello is anybody here saved
again
don't like that why are you saving why
would you be saving right now saving is
not the thing that you should be doing
you should be helping me not die not are
we done
we're done with the weird [ __ ] we've
done we're done we're not done are we
we're not done
bear trap a bear trap I would never have
noticed it I would have walked right
into it million percent chance I would
have walked right into that thing bear
trap hmm peculiar I'll have to trap a
horrible monstrosity monster in there I
caught a moose I think I caught a moose
Oh moose got away I'll get him next time
Dan mooses mooses are so slippery the
most slippery of mammals Meese anyway
see you around moose see you around why
am I so slow bear trap moose your time
is good hello are you okay there I don't
think they're okay
[Music]
did I get you high it was up that a
butthole face
alright cool see you around see you
around okay good door was that that door
wasn't right oh yeah you know I was
checking them all but I withdraw my
curiosity I'm going in no I'm not going
in see that was a trick of the trick mmm
I hate you I'm going in Oh was that it
maybe I should calm down hmm interesting
interesting interesting interesting
interesting it's a surprising number of
urinals in this hospital you're gonna
open up again for me you ready to
emotional tough on me wrong with you
where's your mask Jesus who's there
better find out Oh what am I supposed to
trust that who are you sorry I didn't
mean to scare you with my scary ask face
that's worse that's worse what you just
did why are you up against a bar like
this
who does this I'm not trying to scare
you who did this to you I don't remember
I don't even know how I got here yeah
neither do i we're so similar reviving
our wavelengths are matching up you have
beautiful eyes all right let's think
there are no windows so we're probably
in some kind of underground facility
Stillwater is silent well that was easy
all right
what I said we're in Stillwater asylum I
heard that but how wasn't it close how
do you know that anyway are you one of
the patients I hope not
are you I don't think so even though
that would explain some things okay no
need to panic we'll find the way out
right sure buddy sure wink wink wink one
you don't go up I'm bars standing like
this when everything's gonna be okay
I'll stay here all right
cool dude nice uh hi I do remember one
thing just going up against the bars I
do remember one thing don't bet it's
placing downtown a music shop the
boardwalk something the boardwalk
vintage music shop on orchid lane the
one that I know so specifically the one
next to that blue mailbox
well that one oh I spent every third
Sunday there have you been there I used
to go there when I was still in school
and they had these bizarre instruments
inside right I wonder if they're still
open they are I see it on my way to work
were you there when they caught you I
don't know maybe but I didn't visit the
boardwalks since high school I doubt
that there's any connection yeah you're
probably right
what
okay I guess I can put something in the
bar hey you remember anything else she
hung your mask look familiar
you bet I can't see you take it off your
face then you idiot
or I'll be back I don't know exactly
what I'm looking for alright anyway I'm
gonna go I don't know where I'm going I
can't go okay I can't leave alright
friend I didn't get your name I wouldn't
remember it if I did but I didn't get
your name
what am i doing oh it was a path oh it's
a rusty in here please tell me those
aren't footprints on the ground oh this
door is a little funny Oh weird color
door oh yeah I'll save thank you thank
you
I don't usually find those you usually
do it for me
cool thanks thank you for that what are
you about to do to me fine it's just a
worm door full of worms it's normal
actually I could count on two hands the
number of times I can't go about all
these okay I didn't think that I could
go Oh bear trap mash stupid
[Laughter]
oh hey how you doing I didn't know that
there was more than one of you or you
got away I oh there's a bear trap there
hey buddy hey I'm right here oh it's
hilarious when it happens to you
hilarious when it happens to you glogg I
was never taught not to drink med kits
in school if the choir of the Damned
could get on with it
oh I don't I don't feel like I needed to
go through that I feel like that was an
unnecessary adventure oh oh
stomach is wide open
laces sound like he's got an opening go
for the stomach it's wide open looks
like there's something inside
all right well sure to hand in put the
handed my hand v hand this ain't my hand
there it goes there's no way I'm doing
that without glue excuse me baby I need
some gloves big bouncy baby baby honking
baby that baby was big and bass honking
that was a big paws on convey a bee
all right anyway he's locked and an oven
squeak oh no I don't like it big empty
rooms give me the creeps
I don't like it slow again
my spider-sense is the worst the texwood
monsters nearby but I get row slow I
choked in a
Hey sure am I gonna get gloves in here
floating another world demon baby
alright cool
this is great lots of pianos though so
you know their music education budget is
pretty good oh this is the wrong hallway
Oh butt hole in the oh I'm fine oh okay
one of seven one of seven what one of
seven what project did Bifrost the
effect of loosen is genic drugs on
mentally unbalanced people the use of a
B C drugs short positive but short-term
effects
results improved significantly when
injected in the trim with a mix of
simple sleep peers after creating a
mental map of the patient we're using
the key elements from their painful
memories to set a certain dream
narrative without direct control of the
dreams narrative it becomes a question
of luck and may produce negative effects
vision 6 is heart attack which nines
reinforced fear of the dark part number
67 mr. Flint suggested that the new
crystal storage based VR technology in
combination with strong hallucinogens
could allow us to set our own narrative
unfortunately the system's limitations
don't allow us to adapt to the dream
world of the patient's condition spirit
narratives that required hundreds of
hours of human work didn't show
themselves effective as they would lack
in flexibility seeker report
eighty-seven a possible solution could
be dr. ferral artificial conscience
jim's project okay apparently he was
able to create an AI based on the
crystal data storage technology and
integrated by five digital copies of the
human brains
I am Burroughs or Ruby Jayden gray of
the attempts to cop conscious gems have
failed when isolated false crystals
behaviors or self-destructive code I am
sorry for adopting that accent for the
I've worst Oh God
we still don't understand that dr.
Faraday I doesn't follow earth it's like
there's some kind of dark matter that
maintains our stability and this
accident
all over the place so I'm never gonna do
that again so don't expect me to I
cannot promise that I won't do it again
all right
where am I going it always feels like
I'm going in in a complete minute that's
a face that's a face that's a big face
that's a big big face big face big face
lick see and it looks like your face why
does it look like your face licks and
licks and it looks like your face does
all right cool good face yeah I don't
know what it is the level design is very
good because it feels like I'm going in
random directions but somehow I always
end up somewhere that apparently I need
to be in know how that happens kind of
weird but I like it okay
ah doctor fair incants the special
commission that these conscious gems
project Bifrost could be used as a
supercomputer in the Eden Project but in
that case we'll need a new power point
three Miller to the event from the by
Perez laboratory conscious gems were
successfully integrated into the beifuss
project seven oh the villain patient
survived and so significant improvements
in their mental health the effect only
while consuming the ABC drugs dr. Adam
argued that the lives of our four
mentally unstable patients are nothing
compared to the great cause of the
project and insisted on amplifying by
first team and integrating prisons is
amazing.i our human resources meanwhile
dr. may about all claim that the die
Batory must prioritize the safety of
patients
maybe dr. Miyamoto's got a point there
mmm maybe Miyamoto's got a miyamoto
point I'm a guy please let this let me
escape the face I would love to escape
the face can I escape the face can I get
away from the face I am stuck in the
face the face is me and I am the face
the face is all that I have did i bug it
and like trying to leave the area too
soon and I got stuck in the face juice
and all the face lube got caught in my
gears and my computer and I can't move
anymore all right cool face face oh god
it was I was just free of the face and
then it all you know I see you around
kids see around all right now I'm free
so where am I going now here this way oh
no not again
there's no face there's not even a face
here okay just the butthole three of
seven the results of the investigations
were announced at the extreme I'm giving
up on the accident extreme meaning
number 26 apparently the conscious of a
few deceased patients persisted in the
system thanks to the activity of gems
who managed to stabilize their digital
Souls we still don't fully comprehend
the mechanics of that process in the
role digital patients will or are
playing in the system new experiments
showed an increase in pass rates by 17%
but even though these patients seemingly
managed to overcome their past traumas
without relying on the ABC drugs their
actual success in real life is yet to be
confirmed
doctor Miyamoto presumed the integration
of digital souls of the dead patients
ameliorated the system's capacity to
create personalized narratives and that
it might be proof of the Jemez self
learning mechanism okay doctor Ferran
insisted on stopping the experiments
until we were entirely understood by
Frost digital Tunch and stabilizing
properties and the way those new souls
interact with it
staff voted against this decision today
a new incident of integration of alien
conscience was recorded from the
conversation logs we can conclude that
after a failed therapy session a patient
decided to voluntarily become a part of
this system the Jemez refused to talk to
anyone except dr. Miyamoto and dr.
Ferrand what are these gems
what are these consciousness jumps
you're talking about what to say oh you
just gonna throw that out nowhere no no
oh no oh no you're fast you're fast why
are you so fast go to the face
Oh where'd you go don't trust like that
where'd you go I don't trust like that
okay also what's with this room weird
what's with your sack I don't like your
sack it's at the piano though there's a
pianos I got an achievement called
Easter egg I don't know why I was
attacked by the pianos the face my face
I was attacked by the pianos the pianos
try to kill me oh they're still trying
to kill me with their balls sack why do
you why you sack so big okay so what do
i do do I leave am i leaving I'm dead my
head what this dying part of it or was
dying not part of it I didn't mean to
die I thought it would just game over
and end it but I guess I've never died
in this game before I feel like I want
to go back and try but I don't know what
it means
good morning so how is it going did you
prepare your speech already what speech
known has told you then I have good news
for you there are rumors about you
getting a raise so if you don't want to
disappoint your father get your ass to
the meeting wait isn't it at 11 a.m.
they changed it to 9:30 what why didn't
anyone warn me called you last evening
Carol picked up the phone okay see you
there didn't we talk about the phone at
the table yeah sure did you know about
the meeting sorry I totally forgot about
it really do you know how in the
examination because of one of your
meetings
go ahead honey today could be really
important day for me for us do the
examination at the end of the week do as
you wish you should don't want this
right of course I do
we have to know for sure if it's not
because of me okay you're probably right
I'll go
thank you I have so many questions and
doc never mind I'm done okay my bid is
done I am done doing my bit you found
the second tutors agent seven jack p.m.
Jack bowel movement secret death that's
sacred up yt 12
what is this breathing I don't like it
and we're done no we're not done
interesting okay I'm here now did I get
the rubber gloves
I am so alarming buh buh buh buh I knew
you were there I knew you were there oh
there's another one of you all right
goodbye okay so I'm so confused
second tours Oh secateurs your mane
scissors you just pronounced scissors
really dumbly I like seeing what was
that I'll find out for myself don't
worry
if I'm Gordy oh my dad am I being ripped
apart the sensations are oddly film
similar to being ripped from plain oh
I'm dead legitimately I'm I'm actually
but what what but I say it's so far what
no you're just straight-up killed me
you'd learn me down dog always just kill
me you just straight-up kill me is that
what you do you dick I guess I should
have come back here and saved but I
didn't know that I was just gonna get
killed you gave me the second purse how
long's your JB JA all right I'm gonna in
this one here that's dick that's dick
move that's big dick move I'll start
this episode getting back to where I was
okay cool that's great all right either
way this game is really really really
interesting but I'm so utterly confused
I'm sure it's all gonna make sense later
but the squirt stories jumping around so
much so much be the way I like it and
it's very scary so thank you everybody
so much for watching I am gonna play
this to completion I don't know how long
the game is probably a couple hours
maybe a few let's see so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]